madame monsieur bonsoir
voici l'extrait que nous allons
développer dans ce journal jacques
chirac rappelle à l'ordre lionel jospin
en décrochant son téléphone dès le
retour à paris du premier ministre ce
soir hubert védrine ministre des
affaires étrangères affirme que les
propos du pr neil sont fondés sur le
coeur et la conviction
l'inauguration du salon de l'agriculture
six cent mille visiteurs attendus le
premier d'entre eux le président de la
république avec une sage rencontre josé
bové son livre à la main house de
soulagement pour tous les animaux
domestiques à partir de demain ils
pourront rentrer en grande bretagne sans
subir une quarantaine de six mois une
mesure qui aura avec cliff plus d'un
siècle le prêt-à-porter le talent des
créateurs qui a dit pour l'hiver la
collection val-e-marne mais par cl du
four une mode qui ne se prend pas au
sérieux mais plein de talent
le retour de lionel jospin paris suivie
de la sévère mise au point du président
de la république n'a certainement pas
clos ce chapitre délicat de la
cohabitation certes jacques chirac a
pris l'initiative d'appeler par
téléphone le chef du gouvernement pour
lui rappeler qu'il n'y avait qu'une
seule politique de la france à
l'étranger
et c'est vrai qu'hubert védrine n'a
tenté de désamorcer toute mauvaise
interprétation des propos de lionel
jospin
mais au fond chacun reste sur ses
positions les images tournées hier à
ramallah seront là pour le rappeler et
les commentaires politiques continuaient
de s'ajouter les uns aux autres tout au
long de ce dimanche arnaud boutet marie
laure gendre 21h15 hier soir l'avion du
premier ministre en provenance de gaza a
atterri à l'aéroport charles de gaulle
la délégation française compte une
quarantaine de personnes dont plusieurs
ministres
fin du voyage écourtée après les
incidents de samedi matin lionel jospin
se montre souriant il tire un premier
bilan de son séjour mais refuse de
parler d'échec
cette tout voyage à bord oui sa
rencontre avec jacques chirac
crosby matin devant le conseil des
ministres contact autrement dit il
n'entend pas modifier son agenda et
répondre à la convocation du président
de la république jacques chirac a donc
décroché lui-même son téléphone peu
avant minuit pour sévèrement rappelé à
l'ordre
lionel jospin dans un communiqué
l'elysée réaffirme la constance de la
politique étrangère de la france et l'
équilibre qui inspire l'action de notre
pays au proche orient action qui
demeurent inchangées l'opposition
profitent de l'aubaine et tire à boulet
rouge sur le premier ministre
l'intéret de la france n'est pas de
changer de politique au proche-orient et
je souhaite donc que monsieur jospin
tourner la page et ferme cette
parenthèse qu'il a il faut le dire
malencontreusement ouverte
il a tenté quelque chose qui n'avait
jamais été fait jusqu'à présent et s'est
servi de la politique étrangère à
l'étranger pour régler des comptes en
politique intérieure et ça je crois que
c'est une erreur tout ce qu'ils ont fait
avant lui n'ont pas été récompensés
normal depuis ce matin hubert védrine
vient à la rescousse étant d'expliquer
pourquoi lionel jospin a qualifié de
terroriste les attaques du hezbollah ce
cours il a je crois laissé par l'esa et
son émotion et son coeur il l'a fait
d'une façon très forte très vigoureuse
très convaincu par ce que ce qui
commande tout je le répète c'est la
recherche de la paix laissez-moi second
objectif minimiser cette crise de la
cohabitation pas de tout avoir sur la
diplomatie et sur la politique étrangère
française dans la mise en oeuvre de
cette politique étrangère chacun y
apporte sa
sa tonalité sa personnalité sa
sensibilité sa contribution et que au
total la france parle d'une seule voix
ce matin au salon de l'agriculture
jacques chirac n'a voulu faire aucun
commentaire
il s'expliquera avec lionel jospin en
tête à tête mercredi avant le conseil
des min et déclarations pro israélienne
de lionel jospin ont provoqué vous savez
la réprobation voire la colère du monde
arabe aujourd'hui à naplouse en
cisjordanie
les étudiants palestiniens ont brûlé des
portraits du premier ministre français
quelques 200 étudiants défilent et
pourtant des grands drôle si d'autres
mousse à hébron plusieurs milliers de
manifestants sympathisants du hamas s'en
sont faits au drapeau français
le ministre des affaires étrangères
hubert védrine estimé ce soir que ces
incidents n'était pas vraiment spontané
quand l autorité palestinienne elle en
rend responsable le mouvement islamiste
enfin au liban dans les rues du fort de
saïda ce cortège conduit par le ministre
du travail représentant du président
pouvoir qui dénonce l'agent américain
juste part dès ce matin le hezbollah
réclamait des excuses de lionel jospin
l'occasion pour nous de resituer sur le
terrain ce mouvement dont la branche
armée a tué fin janvier sept soldats
israéliens provoquant la riposte
israélienne sur les installations
électriques libanaise bernard lebrun et
jean-françois hoffman se sont rendus aux
signes dans
le portrait d'un fondateur du hezbollah
la ville et ses soixante mille habitants
et la position militaire israélienne de
d'apcher vision du sud liban à la
frontière de la zone occupée
il porte l'uniforme noir du hezbollah
littéralement les fous de dieu et sont
dirigées par une hiérarchie religieuse
chiite mouvement fondamentaliste pour
les uns organisation terroriste pour les
autres le hezbollah se veut d'abord un
parti politique libanais est très
structuré avec désormais neuf députés au
parlement devait et contrôlant de
nombreuses mairies du sud liban comme
nabatiyeh la branche armée du hezbollah
la résistance islamique vit ses recrues
dans ses rangs monte à la tribune le
secrétaire général du parti cheikh
hassan nasrallah sa première apparition
publique depuis les frappes sur les
stations électriques
en clair voici explicitée par un député
son message nous allons continuer la
résistance à cessieu est simple jusqu'au
retrait de l'armée isrélienne sublimant
les les opérations de résistance ne sont
pas liées aux négociations
ou bien aucune raison politique qui dit
aujourd'hui intensifier et demain c'est
celle dans l'immédiat pas de riposte est
pas question de filmer les combattants
il faut se contenter de ces cassettes de
propagande où l'on voit des résistants
islamique équipe et de m-16 amérique
alors le hezbollah montre sa vitrine
sociale tels l'hôpital d'al jeanne de
nabatiyé maternité consultation
laboratoire et pharmacie tout ici est
moins cher parce que financée par le
parti et l'hôpital est ouvert à tous les
docteurs de la ville y compris des laïcs
il chante en anglais
l'école elle aussi est financé par le
hezbollah même si la scolarité est
partiellement payante pour les familles
pas d'instruction religieuse spécifique
on apprend le français langue du liban
tout comme l'arabe
pour autant la politique ne reste pas à
la porte de l'école c'est la semaine de
la résistance nous dit on le thème des
cours de dessin porte sur la situation
politique dans la région
l'influent ans se fait clairement sentir
les grands frères syriens iraniens
veille sur le hezbollah est justement la
volonté de négocier de l'ain l'évolution
politique de l'autre ne sont pas sans
influencer deux parties chine revenons à
présent sur la question de la sécurité
défaillante qui entourait le premier
ministre hier matin à l'université de
birzeit à un dispositif qui en tout cas
n'a que très mal protégés le premier
ministre alors comment peut-on décoder
ces images de quasi émeute qui nous
restent en mémoire
hervé brisse n'est d'abord des
manifestants anti jospin sur la gauche
une voiture blanche sur tille suivi par
deux autres véhicules de sécurité
arrivent ensuite la voiture officielle
du premier ministre français la
délégation s'apprête à pénétrer
l'université de bir zeit et déjà le ton
est donné
à l'image de cet homme en cravate
les membres du service de protection des
hautes personnalités sont sur le
qui-vive il ya de quoi
la visite commence dans un climat tendu
ce n'était pas le cas pour hubert
védrine il y a trois ans au même endroit
1 deux véhicules l'escort de la police
palestinienne
et cette fois considérable en tout cinq
voitures précède le ministre français
des affaires étrangères en soit de
novembre 97
hubert védrine vient se rendre compte
sur place de l'utilisation des fonds
français qui alimente l'université le
climat est bon et pourtant les gardes du
corps encadrent le convoi d'autres
encore sont là en uniforme cet homme aux
bérets rouges c'est l'art mais pas les
signes et ceux opérés vers son de la
police palestinienne
ils sont là en arrière-plan en veste
bleue le barbu qui sourit cet albert à
gazarian directeur des relations
extérieures de l'université il avait
organisé cette visite de même que celle
de lionel jospin y est et face aux
manifestants il était sûr de les avoir
convaincus de rester calme à quatre
reprises les autorités françaises
avaient vérifié avec lui jusque dans les
moindres détails la halte du premier
ministre et c'est donc lui qui a promis
qu'à l'extérieur rien de grave ne se
produirait
erreur d'appréciation qui n'a pas été
semble-t-il dément qui contrecarrait par
les services français dès lors les cinq
à six hommes de l'escort n'avait plus
qu'un objectif protéger le chef du
gouvernement avec des enveloppes par
éclats lui faire regagner au plus vite
sa voiture blindée
cette absence de maîtrise globale de la
sécurité deviendra certainement un cas
d'école pour experts de la protection
rapprochée à paris jacques chirac comme
à l'accoutumée n'a pas ménagé sa peine
lors de l'inauguration du salon de
l'agriculture le président de la
république est chez lui et en vedettes
américaines cette année josé bové qui a
confirmé que l'on n'est jamais mieux
servi que par soi même puisque le
turbulent leader de la confédération
paysanne offert lui-même
respectueusement son livre à jacques
chirac
eric mazet delphine de tri au nigeria on
se croirait sous une tonnelle au soleil
de midi un dimanche d'été où l'on joue à
reconnaître le sucre et de la carotte ou
le stalles et du céleri
au milieu du brouhaha du salon l'odyssée
végétale c'est l'occasion de sentir les
champignons des sous-bois de faire une
pause
fournir le meilleur état mais on a foulé
jarome de la terre
c'est d'ailleurs la tendance du salon
cette année de donner une autre image
plus rassurante de l'agriculture de
répondre aux attentes du citoyen en mal
d'environnement et de nature par rapport
à des affiches des années précédentes où
l'on voyait des ports au agressif
puissant conquérant pour être vire
mais il faut plus qu'une affiche pour
rassurer le consommateur entre
listériose et dioxyde la sécurité
alimentaire et la préoccupation
principale des visiteurs le premier
d'entre eux jacques chirac a passé
quatre heures au salon pour se livrer à
un exercice qu'il affectionne le contact
avec les animaux et la dégustation des
produits régionaux l'occasion de
rassurer aussi
la sécurité
je suis
les parts sont joints deux
pouvoirs publics fermés chaque jour
d'avancé vers plus de transparence plus
de traçabilité plus de sécurité
sur son chemin le président a croisé
josé bové le leader de la confédération
paysanne
un face-à-face ni la souveraineté
alimentaire dans le cas de l'aviation
donc nous espérons que ces six mois vont
voir mes forces au joueur josé bové a
remis à jacques chirac son nouveau livre
dédicacé s'il vous plaît où il dénonce
les dérives de l'agriculture intensive
le président hu a promis de le lire
vague d'interpellations corse dans le
cadre de l'enquêté sur les deux
attentats commis en plein jour en
novembre dernier
aujourd'hui c'est un des responsables du
mouvement nationaliste corsica viva qui
était placé en garde à vue michel
sindian 10 heures cet homme en blouson
bleu encadrés par des policiers est
peut-être le commanditaire des attentats
commis contre l'urssaf et la dde
d'ajaccio c'est en tout cas ce qu'aurait
affirmé lors d'une audition
l'un des nationalistes de corsica viva
gardé à vue depuis quatre jours au
commissariat
quatre militants de ce mouvement ont été
conduits dans la journée à paris pour
être mise en examen et écroué par un
juge antiterroriste
le 29 novembre dernier les deux
attentats commis en plein jour contre la
dde et l'urssaf avait créé beaucoup
d'émoi et fait sept blessés
l'homme désigné aujourd'hui comme
l'organisateur présumé de ces attentats
s'appelle jo peraldi c'est un ancien
journaliste militant du mouvement
corsica viva nous l'avions filmé hier
soir lors d'une réunion de différentes
organisations nationalistes quelques
heures à peine avant son interpellation
jo peraldi et surtout l'un des quatre
nationaliste qui avait rencontré le 22
janvier dernier en présence du grand
maître du grand orient de france
les responsables du parti socialiste par
ailleurs franc maçon alors que le
gouvernement discute officiellement au
grand jour avec des élus nationalistes
cette rencontre en catimini avait
suscité de nombreuses interrogations
notamment au sein de la classe politique
corse
à madame la vie elle est stupide
personne n'a souhaité au monde discute
de l'avenir de la corse le discuter du
problème de la violence
bien entendu il ya un problème de
violence mais on ne le règle par en
appliquant les lois de la république
en ne le règle pas en discutant et en
plus en discutant de manière occulte les
nationalistes quant à eux sont pour le
moins perplexe entre la politique de
discussion prônée par le premier
ministre et la politique de répression
appliquée par le ministre de l'intérieur
jean pierre chevènement
ils ont du mal distille à voir où se
trouve la ligne du gouvernement en
savoir une spéléologue souffrant de
plusieurs fractures après une chute de
pierres attend les secours qui essayent
d'évacuer la jeune femme qui se trouve à
près de 250 mètres de profondeur dans
une grotte ce sont deux de ses
coéquipiers qui ont donné l'alerté
les deux autres sont à ses côtés le
réseau souterrain est complexe et
particulièrement accidenté rendant
difficile tout accès garde à vue
prolongée pour le jeune automobiliste
qui a fauché hier un groupe de
cyclotouristes dans le gard aujourd'hui
karine comazzi denis par dan ou sont
retournés à nîmes
là même où se rassemblent
traditionnellement le dimanche matin les
amateurs de vélo l'émotion et la colère
de ces cyclotouristes qui ont le
sentiment d'être mise en cause
déjà que nous avons les feux des
projecteurs sur eux et nous partions pas
dans le brouillard ils étaient tous là
ce matin en centre-ville de nîmes au
point de départ de la traditionnelle
échappée dominical rescapés du peloton
accédants t il avait décidé de pédaler
pour semer derrière eux les images de la
bei on les sent nerveux ils se disent
agacés d'entendre parler de mesures de
sécurité
je suis au des précautions je sais pas
quel rôle pour les femmes je pense que
déjà c'est surtout les automobilistes
qui devait faire attention à nous n'est
pas de faire comme il faut et quand ils
voient que ce soit seul ou en groupe
c'est sa captation prenons un esprit qu
on est on est puis comme un des appuis
sur la route on n'est qu'au moins six
qui ceinturent qui suivait sur les
cyclistes se sont sentis mis en cause
par les gendarmes qui évoquait hier le
danger des longs plus tôt si on peut
donner tout de même un conseil aux
cyclotouristes aux touristes qui font
des randonnées le week-end en
particulier c'est d'éviter de se grouper
et de faire plutôt de choisir plutôt de
faire des petits groupes d'une vingtaine
d'une dizaine d'une vingtaine de
coureurs plutôt qu'un groupe e très long
puisque ce groupe eugène effectivement
quelque part la circulation le nombre de
protons multiplient le danger un peu le
ton de sang ça un automobiliste le
considère a quand même comme un obstacle
alors que lui site east seul sur la
route ils comptent pas quoi fédération
de cyclisme ligue contre la violence
routière chacun réclame aujourd'hui un
débat de fond sur le droit des usagers
de la route les revendications des
cyclistes du dimanche sont quant à elles
les mêmes depuis dix ans qu'est ce qu'il
faut améliorer pour éviter des drames
comme hier et piscicoles à la sortie de
la ville et sur un kilomètre
l'argent du conseil général serait bien
utiliser si on construisait ses pistes
faciles à faire puisque à la place en
attendant une table ronde avec les
pouvoirs publics les cyclistes ont rendu
un dernier hommage à leur ami disparu
c'est à nantes que demain devrait se
décider de nouveaux crédits et de
nouvelles mesures pour mieux faire face
aux dégâts des tempêtes et de la marée
noire
sous la présidence de lionel josse pas
de comité interministériel devrait
annoncer des dispositifs mieux adapté
parmi les revendications de la
population un interlocuteur unique à
monsieur ou madame marée noire reportage
olivier sio gabriel kenya dans le
morbihan sur la plage professionnels des
bénévoles ont provisoirement cédé la
place aux promeneurs
les lieux sont à peu près propre mais
l'inquiétude notamment pour le tourisme
et la pêche est toujours présente une
inquiétude relayée par des élus qui
après deux mois de marée noire ne savent
toujours pas exactement qui fait quoi et
il nous paraît pas tout à fait normal
que les collectivités locales soient
mises à contribution autant qu'elles le
sont actuellement
et nous souhaiterions que l'état nomme
en somme un monsieur marée noire ou un
madame marée noire tant au niveau de
l'état que de la région et que des
départements ou au niveau local les
cafouillages des premiers jours ont
laissé des traces et notamment auprès
des associations qui se sont beaucoup
investis et n'ont pas toujours été payés
de retour elle aussi souhaite à l'avenir
être plus étroitement associés aux
prises de décision on a été associé de
force 3 le dynamisme des associations
qui ont montré à cette occasion leur
capacité à réagir mais je crois que à
l'avenir il faut dix ont
institutionnalisé la méthode et et faire
en sorte que les associations soient de
fait inclus dans les dispositifs les
moyens mis en oeuvre ne sont pas en
cause de ce point de vue tous le disent
l'état a fait ce qu'il fallait
la ligue de protection des oiseaux a
ainsi pu installer sa clinique dans
l'ancienne base sous marine de lorient
la préfecture règles même les salaires
des 18 permanents
certes il n'arrive plus si chaque jour
qu'une dizaine d'oiseaux mazoutés
mais la menace plane toujours comment
garder le centre de soins en veille que
le temps que le prendre le temps du
pompage d'eau
donc moi je n'ai qu'une hantise depuis
le 12 décembre comme
que c'est des espaces la pompe est
organisé le pompage rapide de l'épave
empêché les navires poubelles de longer
les côtes françaises ce sont les deux
revendications essentielles aujourd'hui
des bretons et des vendéens pour
mozambique ces terribles inondations qui
offert moins à 164 morts les inondations
les plus graves depuis un demi siècle
une situation d'une extrême précarité
pour ces centaines d'habitants qui
devraient être évacués sans compter la
faiblesse des moyens de secours
patrice et charnue les quelques
hélicoptères pour sauver des milliers de
personnes les habitants du mozambique
sont prises au piège de l'eau le cyclone
et line les pluies les inondations les
chasses de leurs terres et ils se
réfugient sur les points les plus
élevées des buttes de terre des toits
des pylônes le niveau du fleuve et des
rivières ne cesse de monter par endroits
de plus de 5 mètres
la situation est plus que critique
il est toutefois possible de sauver
toutes ces personnes en grand danger
c'est catastrophique
il faudrait beaucoup plus days
l'acheminement des secours auxquelles
participent déjà des pays comme les
etats unis la france est très difficile
de très nombreux ponts et routes sont
coupées
l'évacuation des populations mobilise le
peu de moyens disponibles sur le terrain
les vivres commencent à manquer et la
malaria la principale cause de décès
chez les jeunes enfants est en
recrudescence
le mozambique connais sans doute là
d'une des plus grandes catastrophes de
son histoire
déjà si chaotique ces dernières années
sortant à peine d'une très longue guerre
civile
les habitants assistent impuissants à ce
nouveau naufrage
les élections présidentielles au sénégal
le président abdou diouf brigue un
quatrième mandat il est à la tête de
l'état depuis 1980 quelques deux
millions sept cent mille électeurs
devant se prononcer entre huit candidats
dont deux anciens ministres socialistes
passés dans l'opposition
c'est parti socialiste qui est au
pouvoir depuis l'indépendance en 60 la
corruption la pauvreté la nécessité de
changements constitutionnels faut
envisager un possible le deuxième tour à
présent je vous propose ce portrait
croisé de ces deux électeurs à l' image
contrastée du pays
la représente la jeune génération
terriblement démunis l'autre est une
femme militante qui justifie le bilan du
parti socialiste pouvoir pour les deux
cette élection est cruciale pour
l'avenir du sénégal nous correspondant
permanent en afrique
éric meunier rejet motte à 29 ans
elimane et sans emploi et vie de
débrouille
une des ailes et une jeune mère de
famille diplômé en sociologie
deux exemples de jeunes adultes qui
feront l'élection présidentielle au
sénégal
chacun avec ses îles la vie d'elimane se
résume à une perte c'est 2000 ou 3000
français pas de 10 à 20 francs français
qui by faut coûte que coûte trouver tous
les jours de quoi manger et faire vivre
sa famille un père à la retraite
de nombreux frères et soeurs elimane
appartient à ce que les économistes
appellent le secteur informel de
l'économie
la moitié de la population active
sénégalaise il vit au jour le jour son
travail rabattre les clients pour
quelques boutiques du marché central
hier elimane vote pour un candidat de
l'opposition avant tout pour un peu de
justice sociale
je suis sorti avec monde gt1 mécanique
moi je suis là je ne fais pas çi
pasdeloup jusqu'à présent il ya les
étudiants qui n'ont pas de vous suis
allé normalien qui n'ont pas de salaire
actuellement qui sont sortis avec le
diplôme un pied commande j'ai un point
pour que ça mais ils n'ont pas de
salaire
bon là il ya des privilégiés autour de
dieu c'est ça qui si elle est plus léger
il ya des plus légers ici parce que vous
aussi vous voyez il ya des miss qui sont
des belles villas ici il habite paris 6
il n'habite pas ici en vacances beaucoup
de ministres ils ont des maisons à la
petite coque bon à la petite-côte abou
salim saumon dans les beaux quartiers
ouais dans les beaux quartiers et nous
nous vivons ici dans les quartiers
pauvres après des années de militantisme
à l'université de saint louis du sénégal
day a repris sa carte au cercle des
jeunes cadres socialistes il ya cinq
mois par fidélité abdou diouf le
président sortant et pour défendre un
bilan qu'elle estime globalement positif
est le plus exposé parce que c'est lui
qui agit et les pays les autres ne sont
pas n'ont pas géré ces pays-là pas faire
quand elle veut nous montrer son sénégal
c'est ici qu'elle nous emmène le
chantier de la technopole de dakar qui
devrait accueillir des entreprises
modèles si elle reconnaît que tout le
monde n'a pas encore profité de la
croissance
elle estime que le partage est en train
de se faire sénégalais a évolué en
démocratie et moulins en liberté de paix
un livre que d'associations les
sénégalais allez-vous les parfums
l'émergence d'une société civile qui est
considéré aujourd'hui et qui prend la
parole qui défendent les intérêts le
sénégal et vous lire un thème femmes
parce qu'elle est devenue et déjà
aujourd'hui le pensons qu'il faut singer
le président fait quelque chose mais
nous voulons changer avec lui de
conception d'un pays
le sénégal qui se sont retrouvés
aujourd'hui dans un même lieu
isoloirs élection test en allemagne dans
ce land du nord le schleswig-holstein
c'est la première fois que les électeurs
se rendent aux urnes depuis l'éclatement
du scandale de la cd ou la faire des
caisses noires pourraient modifier le
résultat du scrutin
c'est l'ancien ministre de dalles
défense d'helmut kohl qui mène la liste
de son parti et ce soir selon les
premières estimations sortie des urnes
lui spd serait largement gagnant olivier
lerner ils s'attendaient au pire les
militants de la cdm la droite allemande
mise à mal depuis deux mois est certes
vaincu mais pas abattu et c'est une
surprise et on a déjoué les pronostics
on a fait beaucoup mieux on ne
l'espérait certains nous plaçait sous la
barre des 30% et ils se sont trompés
la gauche peut crier victoire avant le
scandale des pots de vin et des caisses
noires la droite était donnée gagnante
ici elle collectionne les chapeaux et
les bagues
la présidente du parlement réélu elle
collectionne également les victoires
celle ci plus facile à obtenir que les
autres la droite allemande doit regarder
la gauche avec envie tout lui sourit les
affaires de l'accès des ou ne se sont
pas transformées en affaire d'état la
crise est à droite
rien qu'à droite le très médiatique folk
roues et ancien ministre de la défense
candidat malheureux n'a pas tout perdu
dans cette bataille régionale son nom
est cité fréquemment pour occuper la
tête de son parti
une défaite honorable pour la droite
l'allemand milliard $ parce qu'ils
gardent aussi tous une champ d'action
l'extrême droite ne pourra en tirer
aucun bénéfice
une petite révolution en grande-bretagne
partir de demain et après plus d'un
siècle la fin de la quarantaine pour les
animaux domestiques obligé de passer six
mois dans des chenils spécialisés pour
éviter toute propagation éventuelle de
la rage à la clé pour le début de cette
semaine à passeport pour animaux un
woofer de soulagement benoît duquesne
lesdits frais toilettes heureuse la vie
sera un grand jour la baptiser son corps
à la fin d'une pratique vieille d'un
siècle d'une obligation tout britannique
est presque barbares la quarantaine pour
lundi oui c'est pour lundi on a fait ça
pour tous les gens qui nous ont aidés
pour leur métier
la quarantaine six mois d'isolement dans
les années 80 chenil du royaume hassa
sanitaires contre la rage un passage
obligé pour tous les animaux candidats à
l'entrée en grande bretagne gary tom
flynn est le maître des lieux il règne
sur une soixantaine de chiens et 40
chats son chenil est propre bien tenu
presque agréable
rien de traumatisant qu'on style pour
ses pensionnaires les chiens ici ne
souffre pas de stress
leurs propriétaires sont convaincus que
les chiens sont stressés et du coup ce
sont eux qui stresse
ces bombes est difficile pour les
propriétaires que pour les chiens à 3500
francs par mois pour un chien un peu
moins pour un chat c'est vrai que la
pension était bien tenue après six ans
de lutte ce sont bien les propriétaires
qui ont obtenu la fin de cette pratique
ce couple d'américains est arrivé en
décembre dernier avec ses treize chat
touches sont en quarantaine alors qu'un
vaccin est un test sanguin suffirait à
s'assurer contre la rage depuis le temps
que j'aille justin et a jamais eu
vraiment de guerre de rage durant la
quarantaine entre donc très demandé à
quoi ça sert de provins pour l'instant
seuls 22 pays exempt de la rage sont
concernés par cette levée de la
quarantaine et l'instauration d'un
système braconniers de passeport pour
animaux un passeport qui leur donnera le
droit pour la première fois depuis cinq
ans d'entrer librement en grande
bretagne
en france les forêts dévastées par la
tempête tarde d'être nettoyé pour la
plus grande inquiétude des sapeurs
pompiers qui craignent que les voies
d'accès bouchés par les débris d'arbres
met en péril la sauvegarde de ces
massifs particulièrement sec ou moment
des saisons à risque reportage dans le
sud de la charente maritime entre royan
et marraines christophe devals embrasse
alain darrigrand les pompiers appellent
cela les tranchées 150 km de pistes qui
quadrillent la forêt de la coudre en cas
d'incendié elle permet d'intervenir en
tous points du massif
en moins de vingt minutes ou plutôt
permettait les dégâts de la tempête un
tiers à peine du réseau est praticable
délais d'intervention au coeur de la
forêt n'ont plus 20 mai 45 minutes
la différence peut s'avérer
catastrophique ces 25 minutes peuvent
être fondamentalement gravissime pour
nous c'est à dire c'est à dire que le
feu pas avoir pris une extension tels
que dès lors que nous arriverons à la
vie il sera trop fort pour nous
la forêt est en péril c'est évident car
la saison à risque s'annonce le
printemps plus dangereux encore que
l'été alors on travaille d'arrache-pied
on a fait venir des spécialistes
les forestiers sapeurs des bouches du
rhône on l'entend parfois être très gros
chantier avec des ordres qui sont
tombées de part et d'autre qui obstruent
complètement le passage nokla il ya un
très gros travail réalisé et dans le
parti lyon pour les liaisons vers les
plages on n'a pas encore travaillé j'ai
grandi en priorité de de me remettre en
état et de permettre facilement la lutte
contre l'incendié dans toute la zone qui
est proche de l'océan
là où les touristes il ya le plus grosse
concentration des touristes en été
on a une première équipe qui est devant
nous qui est chargé de couffé d'abattre
les arbres qui sont dangereux et de
couper tous mes bras tous les branchages
et derrière il ya la machine qui a été
moyen qui a pour mission de couper tout
ce qui est branché flotte était regroupé
de manière à ce que la masse de
combustible soit ramené aux plus petits
volumes possible de manière à ce qu'il
ne puisse pas brûler facilement bien
nettoyer les planchers pourront
également jouer leur rôle de couple mais
il faudra encore beaucoup de travail
pour sécuriser l'ensemble de la forêt
les pompiers de royan ont déjà demandé
que pour cette saison on leur met à
disposition des canadair
participation record pour cette 25e
édition de l'enduro du touquet remporté
par le motard et thierry bethys marque
maisonneuve et m'a dit diawara se sont
intéressés à ces passionnés pilotes
émérites ou ensablées au départ ils sont
plus de mille tous ensemble à l'arrivée
ils sont toujours mille mais un seul à
la fois c'est le goulet le goulet c'est
tellement simple que son est presque
définitifs les poireaux ce sont les
pilotes qui restent plantés dans le
sable
parmi eux franck numéro 550 un poireau
qui n'a pas pris racine
je suis pas le boulet franck ne fera que
deux tours pourtant ils s'étaient
préparés
traders à la bourse avec ses copains le
touquet c'est la première course au
programme étude de dunes avec un ancien
champion du monde
un quasi totale et de tous entoure le
parcours évoluer va se creuser
après les reconnaissances barbecue et
eaux minérales pour franck
mais dans le touquet il y à d'autres
feux de camp et des eaux minérales sans
doute frelaté cela va durer toute la
nuit
il a dormi cette nuit eric roca loi ses
copains l'appellent croquettes
il boit de l'eau et mange des pâtes
depuis six mois pour la course
le touquet c'est sa course il y a deux
ans il était 10e depuis il rêve de faire
mieux 5e ou 6e car il veut plus il veut
faire le dakar
cette année coincé dans la meute il a
manqué son départ et n'a jamais pu
rattraper l'autre spécialiste local
arnaud demeester avec tout le monde et
puis après c'était la course à
l'échalote qu'il a fallu je réponds tout
le temps tout le temps tout le temps
quand je me suis vidé déjà de la moitié
de la cour a rejeté bible 18e ce soir
croquettes et déçu mais il ira faire la
fête avec ceux qui l'ont aidé à se
préparer du nord où l'ensemble c'est un
mec extra donc moi je
toujours un soupirant de l'année
prochaine franck roquettes et les autres
espèrent bien vivre une autre histoire
de potes dans le goulet
de la mode prêt-à-porter de l'hiver 2000
sur le podium du carrousel du louvre la
collection balmain emmenés par gilles
dufour l'éclat des couleurs et des
matières nicolas cornu langlois bernard
codeurs bernie incandescent musique rock
pop modèles incluent au flash et star
c'est parti pour une semaine frénétique
voir sic et d'élus chez balmain gilles
dufour donne le ton j'aime bien les
choses à feu poétique surréaliste est
déviée ensuite par exemple vous avez le
fameux le cachemire rosbif en jambon de
bayonne
ils ont aussi des pastilles un peu
partout là où il faut les bottines
ouvertes pour scander le temps faut du
podium et des couleurs acidulées pour
dégeler de vison diabolique il compose
des cocktails de gags ou de tags
mais pour séduire catherine il s'est
aussi s'agir pour inférieur à jupe
dansante va bcbg
c'est plutôt jeune et c'est plutôt mais
c'est une façon de porter les choses ça
vient d'un autre et des vestes très
classique on peut mettre à sa façon
parce qu'on n'est pas obligé de se
déguiser
on aimera en effet porter ces ensembles
aux allure juvénile c'est manteau de
feutre bien coupé décontractée les
pantalons fluides en velours dévoré les
blues ont deux garçons et les mélange de
cuir sur robes de mousseline
cette veste cintrée à boutons brodé
inspiré des ballets russes
et pour les moins téméraires une robe
apparemment sages les dénuder dans le
dos une mode vitaminé par un créateur au
meilleur de sa forme et de son humeur en
islande l'éruption du volcan hekla d'une
très grande intensité des coulées de
lave était visible à plusieurs dizaines
de kilomètres à la ronde
un nuage de fumée de cendre de s'élever
au rendant difficile le survol de ce
volcan est recouvert de neige à cette
époque de l'année
images inédites de ces coulées de lave
sur des versants immaculé c'est la fin
de ce journal je vous en rappelle les
deux principaux titres jacques chirac
rappelle à l'ordre lionel jospin en
décrochant son téléphone dès le retour à
paris du premier ministre ce soir hubert
védrine mise les affaires étrangères a
comme qu'il est proposé l'élève pas sûr
fondée sur le coeur et la collection
l'inauguration du salon de l'agriculture
huit cent mille visiteurs attendus le
premier d'entre eux le président annick
avec une sage rencontre josé bové son
livre à la main dans un instant la météo
nathalie rihouet valeur 5 rendre votre
film l'inspecteur ne renonce jamais avec
clint eastwood
23h40 le dernier journal laurence
ostolaza demain 7h 50 dans les 4 vérités
gérard morin en direct du salon de
l'agriculture aura pour invités du tuyau
président de la fnsea 13h le journal
carole gaessler et rachid arhab à vador
vous retrouverez claude sérillon je vous
remercie de la tractation excellente
soirée